tokyo debuted two of several brand new
olympic sports over the weekend
the first ever surfing competition got
underway at a beach about
25 miles outside the city and the very
first
olympic medals were handed out for
skateboarding jamie yukis is in tokyo
and spoke with one olympian from team
usa
about how these sports are changing the
games hello again jamie
hey anthony hasn't it been fun to watch
you know it wasn't that long ago that
skateboarders were stereotyped as
troublemakers and surfers
as slackers now for the first time in
history they're both being called
olympians along with other new events
like climbing and karate
it's all part of a shift in the games
toward youth culture
and that could mean a whole new
generation of fans for future olympic
[Music]
competitions
[Music]
in southern california skate parks are
as common as starbucks
seemingly one on every block but this
one
is different because now it's training
ground for an olympian you're going to
the olympics yes
as a skateboarder yeah how does that
feel it's
crazy skateboarding once a
counterculture pastime born out of
rebellion
is now taking center stage at the
world's biggest sporting event
with competitors like jordan barrett
joining the olympic legacy do you feel
like an elite athlete
no i don't i mean like i look at
other elite athletes and i'm not trying
to say that i'm not
driven but it's a different program than
what skateboarding is skateboarding is
just unique in its own self
a lot of people wouldn't call it a sport
i don't even know what people call like
it's a lifestyle it's a
way to express yourself so to showcase
that to the world is
super exciting barrett thinks her
biggest competition
will come from the japanese team but
she's also wondering how olympic
commentators and
viewers will adapt to the new sport
here's another thing that people are
going to have to get used to is the
names of tricks
it's like saying them it just like
sounds ridiculous an eggplant is a
variation of a hand plant
a stale fish is a type of grab lip
slides
disaster so we're gonna hear judges go
she just did the
stale fish yeah i think there'll be a
lot of people googling
yeah i know i hope there's like some
sort of skate dictionary or something
to bring in new fans and to appeal to
the younger generation is very very
important to the olympics
these are x games gold medals ron semio
created the x games back in 1995.
three years later the international
olympic committee added snowboarding
but it took 20 more years to bring
x-game style sports to the summer games
why did it take two decades to get some
of these sports in the summer game
you know skateboarders are very very
protective of their culture
and of their sport and they wanted the
presentation of it to be
right i think it took it took a while
for there to be that comfort level
with the skateboarding community front
10 double yes
the rewards could be huge just this past
january
the winter x games were syndicated to
500 million homes
in 192 countries they attracted 105
million video views
across social and digital media
platforms you're appealing to youth
and these are your fans that are going
to want to stay with you
for a long time does it come down to
money i guess yeah everything comes down
to money
but the ioc isn't just betting on
skateboarding
this year in tokyo it's also adding
climbing karate and surfing
kalohe endino is representing the united
states in the inaugural olympic surf
competition
i've always been a big kind of olympic
nerd i always watch it record it once i
heard that surfing was going to be in
the olympics i was just excited but
unlike most olympic sports this one
depends on mother nature
if the big waves don't roll in it's
harder to compete
and to win i always say it's like tom
brady going out and he can't find the
ball it's like
that's how it is for sure no matter what
happens in tokyo
fans of extreme sports see the olympics
as yet another example
of once obscure hobbies becoming
professional sports
add in sponsorships and tv viewers and
that means more young people can become
professional athletes in the future
we all want to do what we love for a
living
and that's what the olympics are
allowing skateboarders and surfers and
rock climbers
to continue to do
a good example of that is an extreme
athlete who came up to ron semio a few
years ago
thanking him for creating the x games by
saying now i don't have to work at the
deli anymore
as for jordan barrett her big moment on
the olympic stage comes next wednesday
august 4th
when she rides in the women's
skateboarding park competition we wish
her luck
yes we do jamie yuka sports in tokyo
thank you and you know it's cool because
it did open it up to so many more
people in their interests yeah well they
clearly have athletic skills to do oh
sure
yeah i would think it would be hard to
judge surfing particularly when
everybody gets a different wave
but as they said these are cultures and
and these are also things that
most ordinary people can access on any
given day which i love seeing them in
the games
i would like a skating dictionary though
because i don't know eggplants stale
fish
disaster yeah gotta watch you gotta
check it out